I don't think anyone's afraid of failing
I think everyone's afraid of other
people seeing themselves fail and
getting judged for it there's short-term
pain that you have to go through when
you do anything new unless you're
immediately successful which almost no
one is you usually have to take a step
back in order to take two three 10 steps
forward so I was a consultant for
example and I had all the status for
somebody at my age working at a you know
big firm I graduated in 3 years I had
all that stuff but then when I quit that
to start basically being a personal
trainer at a gym that was a big decrease
in status in terms of my like relative
standing compared to my per and I
remember when I would have women come to
the gym be like did you go to college
there's a big pill of humility that I
think a lot of people aren't willing to
take because it hurts to drop in status